I know the former president put out a
statement yesterday
um
in which you could say that his anger
and indignation was probably a 10 out of
10. how is he today
well president Trump's doing good he
knows he's done nothing wrong but he's
actually very concerned for a country
because the United States we don't do
this in the United States of America as
a constitutional republic this is what
you do in third world countries you try
to take out your number one political
opponent with Sham trumped up charges
and this is totally baseless they're
trying to decide who our next president
is going to be these corrupt prosecutors
with their financial backers are trying
they think they get to decide well
they're wrong the American people will
get to decide who our next president is
he's leading in all the polls and the
truth will will win in this case once
again as he's been under baseless
investigation for seven years now and he
always comes out more clean on the other
side because the truth is on his side
given what you say about the motivations
behind the indictment are you expecting
a number of others as well
well we are ready for anything we know
there are several taxpayer funded
election interference investigations
going on as we speak out of D.C they've
hauled members of our campaign under
before grand juries time and time again
harassing us for you know president
Trump's complete constitutional rights
uh to contest the 2020 election and also
his rights under the presidential
records act those investigations are
baseless but we know they have an agenda
and they also have an agenda in Georgia
as well that was totally a lawless
investigation with the four person
coming out and doing interviews and
leaking grand jury information and this
is so corrupt Samantha this cannot
happen in a great country like ours and
we're losing our status as a great
nation as we turn into uh just any other
Banana Republic that locks up political
opponents that suspends the rule of law
that weaponizes law enforcement and
Riggs elections and we cannot lose this
is the justice system is going to
continue to fight this is the justice
system and if you don't if you don't
trust in it then what is that how does
he respond to that is either fight or
flight isn't it is he going to be
encouraging his supporters to stand up
and fight
this is not a legitimate justice system
this is a show me the man I'll show you
the crime and look at what Nancy Pelosi
said she said oh he'll have a chance to
prove his innocence that's not how it
works the United States of America
that's not how it works in the justice
system you're a Presumed Innocent you
have to be proven guilty and they've
always presumed president Trump guilty
of what is his crime threatening their
corrupt political power that's what this
is about since he came down the
escalator they've harassed him his
family his business and they have never
found anything they spied on his
campaign they tried to frame him for
collusion with Russia when it was
Hillary Clinton and you know they keep
saying no one's Above the Law well
apparently a lot in the political class
are Hunter Biden Joe Biden taking money
from the Chinese Communist Party Nancy
Pelosi insider trading the the list goes
on and on the clintons don't get us
started that they are above the law and
they have never had the political system
the justice system used in a political
way against them but they've done this
to the most popular let me ask you um
Stormy Daniels has gone on record this
evening saying that she has received
death threats and she's anticipating
violence in New York on Tuesday uh does
the president condemn any kind of
violence
president Trump certainly does not want
to see violence I think the only people
that want to see violence are the same
people who want to capitalize off of it
for January 6. you know it's the
corruption in law enforcement federal
agents and the like they would like to
see violence but we do not we want
peaceful protests we want people to
exercise their constitutional rights
if we do see violence because your fever
it's fever pitch isn't it people the
fevers are running very high over this
if we do see violence will he
immediately categorically condemn it and
tell people not to engage in violence
we're telling people to be very smart
and Discerning because anyone who's
talking about violence is probably a
federal agent if we're going to learn
from past experience so obviously the
Maga movement is very peaceful it's been
proven that at every rally we just had a
rally of over 30 000 people in Waco
Texas it's the most fun peace loving
great event you can be at is a trump
rally so that that didn't sound to me
Liz that didn't sound to me like you
were saying that President Trump would
immediately condemn any violence and you
can imagine why people are concerned
about this but the memories of Japanese
still looming very large
look this is a game that the media wants
to play and hype up tensions we don't
want this division we want the country
to come together and they are they are
uniting behind president Trump because
they know he's been wronged once again
and if it can happen to him everyone
knows that it can happen to any one of
us and all of our rights are at stake
our rights is a great free and free
country are on the line so obviously
that's what our goal here is to make
sure that our constitutional rights are
intact and right now they're hanging by
a thread can I just ask whether
president Trump thinks that the death
threats received by Stormy Daniels are
regrettable
I'm sure he doesn't want any death
threats to be issued to anyone we don't
want them coming our way as well we do
not want violence or tension or anything
else we want peace president Trump he's
the one he's the peace candidate he's
the one who would get us out of this
conflict with Ukraine he's the one who
ended endless Wars and didn't get us
into any new ones he's the one who
secured our border and made our country
safe that's what he wants and look what
we have now Alvin Braggs New York
lawlessness crime skyrocketing that is
the violence that they're not pursuing
they're not locking these criminals up
they're actually letting them out
they're moving felonies down to
misdemeanors and yet they're trying to
weaponize the law and throw it all out
to make a non-crime a misdemeanor and
bump it up to a felony this is upside
down it cannot continue and it again the
only people that want that are the
people that aren't Prosecuting the real
criminals and that's these Soros DA's
and it's the justice department and in
D.C they declined to cry
the justice system it is what it is
um he has agreed to the arraignment uh
in New York on Tuesday how is he going
to plan concurrently to be managing his
legal defense we know that there's one
indictment there could be more at the
same time as trying to run his campaign
to be president of the United States
he said it before his whole life has
been a fight he's been under constant
unrelenting attack it has not deterred
him it's actually making him stronger
he's going to continue to fight for the
American people to make America great
again that's all that this is about and
he said it so plainly you know this our
country's on the line either the Deep
State destroys America or we destroy the
Deep State that's why they're coming
after him so hard and that's why they
continue these sham investigations but
do not be concerned about President
Trump he's going to continue to fight
and we will be victorious because the
people are on our side the polling
suggests that the indictment is helpful
in terms of his nomination to the
Republican
um for the Republican nomination not
helpful though to win the White House so
given that given that he wants to be a
winner does he not think maybe why why
bother
well this is clearly election
interference that's what they're trying
to do but we know the American people
see through this and they've seen
through it for seven years now and more
and more people are rallying behind him
because they know he's the number one
threat and everything else uh nothing
else matters because we have a corrupt
ruling class if we don't have free and
fair elections if we don't have the rule
of law we don't have a country and
that's what they're doing they're
destroying the rule of law people are
seeing that and they're saying there's
one guy that they're going after there's
one guy who has the force of tens of
millions of Americans behind him and the
greatest political movement in our
country's ever seen that's why they're
going after him and that's why our
movement is growing but clearly they
want to try to damage him but just like
everything else the Sham impeachments
the Mueller Witch Hunt everything else
it always backfires because the truth
always wins in the truth has been on
Donald J Trump's side speaking of wheels
of Justice I'd just like to know uh what
what president Trump's view is of the
ICC arrest warrant for President Putin
I have not spoken to him directly about
this but I have spoken to him about the
conflict in Ukraine and what we cannot
continue to happen is this endless war
escalation president Trump would get
these two individuals in the room and
would hammer out a deal for peace no one
else will do that no one else is even
willing to talk about it they just want
to keep escalating it and we're talking
about a conflict that could escalate
with nuclear weapons this talk about
violence this is something that's so
unacceptable that would never happen
under President Trump's watch and you
don't get good negotiations by just you
know doing the same old same old of the
corrupt neocon establishment what they
want is an endless war that is
unacceptable and president Trump would
not tolerate it and he would bring peace
and just a final question to you Liz um
no chance that President Trump would um
would engage in a plea deal
he is totally innocent absolutely not